vous êtes justement comme bassam en
place de la république pour ce
traditionnel défilé du 1er mai et leurs
revendications syndicales sont
nombreuses oui alors moi je suis en tête
de cortège si vous vouliez boulevard
voltaire pour se rendre direction nation
quelques tensions eu lieu entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
mais a très vite atténuée alors l'idée
évidemment de sarralbe 200
rassemblements et de dirt faire
ressortir toute la question sociale 1
qu'il y en a qui a été laissé de côté un
vis-à-vis de la crise sanitaire je me
trouve actuellement avec benoît test
benoîte est secrétaire général de la fsu
alors une mobilisation très importante
mobilisation très conséquente
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de l'année
dernière il ya beaucoup de frustration
ne pas pouvoir défiler donc c'était
important cette année à de montrer que
la réforme les questions sociales sont
toujours présentes
oui merci bonjour et effectivement
on est content aujourd'hui et tout le
monde est content de se retrouver les
militants les collègues largement la
population autour effectivement de ses
revendications
comme tous les 1er mai mais c'est vrai
que ça a une saveur un peu particulière
cette année
l'an dernier on n'a pas pu défiler
l'année d'avant c'était aussi compliqué
et quelque part
effectivement il faut que ce soit
aujourd'hui le point de départ d'un
retour de la question sociale
on est à un an d'une élection
présidentielle où le débat finalement se
limite à libéralisme ou autoritarisme
quelque part en tout cas c'est un peu le
débat qu'on veut nous servir et nous on
est là pour dire on ne veut pas que le
débat se passe là dessus on veut pas
toutes les instrumentalisations toutes
ses divisions
on veut discuter modèle social projet de
société et c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en
avant particulièrement la question de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
c'est un point particulier il ya plein
d'autres revendications mais cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage elle est
emblématique parce que finalement on
nous refait le coup de droits sociaux
qui serait pas impossible à supporter à
financer et renvoyer la responsabilité
individuelle du chômage sur les chômeurs
mais c'était la même chose avec les
retraites à on disait les retraités
touchent trop de retraite
il faut leur baisser encore la pension
et ça c'est typiquement le modèle de
société dont on ne veut pas et donc je
pense que c'est en train effectivement
de remonter dans le pays un retour de la
question sociale
ce 1er mai est quand même assez
important et c'était le cas aussi dans
les arrivées ça veut dire que quelques
tensions et exploser des jets de
lacrymogènes qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque justement de voir tout ce
dispositif policier une fois de plus qui
a qui est là pour encadrer
ça signifie quoi
il faut d'abord que la police permettent
d'assurer les manifestants de défiler et
c'est parfois ce qui ne se passe pas ou
pas bien parce qu'il y avait des
techniques de maintien de l'ordre qui
visiblement ne convient pas donc nous à
chaque fois on dit qu'il faut
effectivement assurer la sécurité des
défilés ce n'est pas à nous de l'assuré
évidemment après on espère pouvoir
défiler jusqu'à présent ça se passait à
peu près bien
on espère que ça va bien se passer ça
s'est très bien passé aussi dans les 300
cortèges dans les régions dont qu on est
on est toujours un peu un peu embêté par
le fait de montrer des images de casse
et
et nous on pense que il faut surtout pas
de mouvement violent ça dessert notre
mouvement et on considère qu' on doit
pouvoir défiler normalement on est le
mouvement social organisé
c'est pas parce qu'on est non violente
qu'on va pas être entendus bien au
contraire je pense que si certains
s'adonnent à des violences ou à empêcher
les choses ça ne sert pas du tout notre
mouvement et on espère que effectivement
tout le monde comprendra tout ça et nous
laissera défilé tranquillement on
revenir sur les revendications sociales
on sent que la crise sanitaire a mis de
côté un peu tous et cette question
sociale est ce que alors que au final ça
n'a fait que l'ailé creuser ces
inégalités c'est votre avis également
oui exactement c'est à dire que on a vu
que la précarité
qui existait déjà avant était encore
plus insupportable le mal logement il
est encore plus insupportable quand
c'est en temps de crise dans des petits
logements
on le voit avec beaucoup les jeunes les
jeunes les élèves qu'on a en face de
nous ils sont désorientés ils sont
psychologiquement socialement parfois
intellectuellement désorientés la crise
est très dure parce qu'elle renvoie tout
le monde elle fait que tout le monde se
replie sur soi et donc on a un état
d'esprit dans la population qui va
falloir réparer quelque part il va
falloir vraiment qu'on fasse attention
aux jeunes qu'on fasse attention à la
population qu'on augmente les droits
collectifs au lieu de les respectives
mans la crise elle a mis en lumière
quand même aussi l'utilité sociale et de
certains métiers
les soignants les enseignants les
caissières de supermarché on a justement
montrer que tous ces travailleurs 1re 2e
3e ligne chez plus comment les appels
après tous ces travailleurs étaient
essentielles au fonctionnement de la
société et maintenant il faut
reconnaître et donc reconnaître ça veut
dire aussi augmenter les salaires
améliorer les conditions de travail etc
etc merci beaucoup benoît thèse d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire générale de la fsu
voilà vous l'aurez compris le cortège
est pour l'instant bloqué ici un
boulevard voltaire les forces de l'ordre
bloquent en tête du cortège des jets de
gaz lacrymogènes ont été lancés vers les
manifestants
vous l'avez entendu dans les mots de
benoît test objectif n'est pas justement
de montrer un mouvement violent pour
pouvoir transmettre ce message et
pouvoir défiler en paix jusqu'à nation
merci david